a postal code can tell you a lot about
how the pandemic has impacted someone
just knowing the first three digits can
likely tell you if they've been able to
work from home
had timely access to a vaccine and their
likelihood of getting sick with covet
19.
certain postal codes known as hot spots
can be found across the country
living and working there are essential
workers in workplaces where transmission
is a looming fear
[Music]
he loves his camera it's him and his
his son amanda young kaluchi's brother
godfrey young
was a long time employee at canada post
an immigrant from hong kong
he always worked hard to support his
family he's a very honest person
you know he loves his family he loves
his parents
just two more years and then yo he can
he can finally
you know retire take a break be with his
kids that's right and being with his
family
and then yo um not in a million years
i would have ever thought that kova 19
would hit so close
yo to my family in mid-january godfrey
young showed up for his night shift at
the canada post gateway facility in
mississauga
the sprawling facility is the largest in
the country
thousands of people work here hundreds
at a time in close quarters
the facility was experiencing an active
covet outbreak
and there were close to 280 positive
cases
days after his shift the 62 year old
tested positive for covet 19.
six days later he died since then like
yo
i've been asking that question what
happened like
how
[Music]
canada post has had more than one
outbreak during the pandemic at this
facility
the company declined global news's
request for an interview
and said in a statement that it has
implemented rigorous safety measures to
keep employees safe
and has closely followed advice of
public health officials including
distancing
and screening of employees it says it is
also conducting mandatory rapid on-site
testing at many facilities
including gateway offering paid sick
leave and recently held vaccination
clinics
amanda who's also a city councilor in
markham says it's not enough
essential workers like him have to
dictate that type of
risk every day the question is who's
there to protect them
more deadly and contagious variants have
stricken workplaces in the third wave of
the pandemic
as warehouses manufacturing and food
processing plants
continue to be significant drivers of
transmission
in ontario alone 68 people have died
from covid that they got at work
and more than twenty five thousand
contracted it on the job
but advocates say that number could be
even higher
because not all cases have been reported
every single case
every single death there's someone who
we love
our friends our neighbors our brothers
our sisters our parents or someone's
child
these are not just numbers
dina ladd is the founder and executive
director of the workers action center
an organization that supports workers
and advocates for changes to labor laws
to improve wages
and working conditions we've seen
worker after worker calling our hotlines
you know calling us and saying what what
do i do
you know everyone's lost their job in my
family i have to do this work
but how do i protect myself even before
the pandemic started
some workers in ontario had paid sick
days scheduling rights and a wage
increase
taken away so that context
was very much on our minds when the
pandemic started because we were
thinking oh my goodness they're
forced to go to work and we know
it's good it's going to be brutal
and it's not just ontario canada's labor
market has undergone a radical
transformation in the last few decades
there has been a massive shift towards
precarious work
and increasing use of temp agencies and
subcontracting
leaving workers with fewer benefits and
less job security
a recent study found that 58 of canadian
workers
did not have paid sick leave from their
employer and
all of those issues
create a very unstable feeling create a
real sense of
fear a real sense that you can't really
speak
up because your job is on the line so
labor rights are really a provincial
responsibility and they've taken a
hands-off approach and said
you know go ahead we're not going to
regulate we're not going to intervene
for the past decade hong has been
working at an industrial laundry
facility
unloading and unpacking bags of dirty
linens and garments
he makes less than fifteen dollars an
hour and up until recently
had no paid sick days global news agreed
to hide his identity as he fears
reprisal from his employer
on new year's day hong went to work and
as usual had lunch with a long-time
colleague and friend santi
[Music]
his colleague died in hospital a few
weeks later just one month before he was
to retire
hong says the factory requires them to
wear a mask while they're working
because it's impossible to
when he returned to work extreme fatigue
and swollen legs made it painful to
stand for his 10-hour shift
but he needed the money
months later hong says he's still
suffering long-haul symptoms of covid19
and is too weak to work do you feel this
all could have been
hello good how are you
dr andrew bazary is an expert in social
medicine
he also leads a team of researchers who
have been studying hot spots in toronto
and peel
one of the things we wanted to do was
dive deeper into what
has been driving the heat and the
unequal exposure of covet
they found that 63 percent of people who
live in hot spots are racialized
and more likely to be essential workers
in manufacturing utilities trades and
transport
they're also more likely to be
low-income earners and what we've really
found is that postal code
is code language for the structural
determinants of health
and these health disparities that have
long been in place
buzzari says the data is a wake-up call
that essential workers in these
neighborhoods need urgent protection at
work
and vaccine access because if people are
going to stand up and say
these people are heroes which i fully
endorse
we have to make sure that we're doing
the work and we're providing the
policies and supports
that is more than rhetoric
not having paid sick leave meant workers
often couldn't stay home if they felt
unwell
after mounting pressure ontario mandated
three paid sick days
but the policy is temporary so
labor laws haven't changed to protect
workers
and i think that you know when you go to
work you need to feel confident
that the laws that are there to protect
you
are not just words on a paper but what
we've seen is
um enforcement is not happening
many also argue that provincial
governments were slow to act
and enforce rules and despite new
research suggesting that covet spreads
primarily through airborne transmission
experts say infection control measures
do not focus enough on improving
ventilation
but it's not just up to governments
[Music]
the corn continues along this rinsing
platform
nature's path is a family-run organic
food manufacturer in metro vancouver
these lines run 24 hours a day seven
days a week
argent stevens is the general manager so
we included these plexiglass
and then soon thereafter we increased
the conveyor
so there's more space between the people
at the beginning of the pandemics people
were scared to come into work
and we said well what can we do to
alleviate that concern and make sure
people are safe so we talk to
consultants we talk to experts that led
to changes
plexiglas distancing online and
screening
the company also decided to offer a now
permanent hero pay raise of two dollars
an hour
and increase paid sick leave by two
weeks at its facilities in canada and
the us
it also decided to focus additional
efforts on an area of transmission
concern
the lunchroom making it the first in
north america to install these
specialized uv lights and air filtration
system
because we know that when people have to
take off their mask when they're sitting
down in a lunch room
that that's also when they're vulnerable
the changes at all four locations cost
the company close to four million
dollars u.s
but they say it's been worth it at the
bc facility there has been no workplace
transmission
and we feel that if we look after our
team members
eventually you know the profits will
come i mean a lot of companies where
people don't have this
they'll come to work sick because they
don't have another option
and for those advocating for change that
is key
recognition that the work these people
do is essential every day
pandemic or not the one silver lining
from this pandemic if
there could be ever such a lining
is is the fact that there has been a lot
more exposure
on these invisible types of work
that public consciousness that awareness
of the fact that you know we need to be
concerned
about the conditions of the cashier at
the grocery store because
if she's not well then that affects my
health
we have to do this work we have no
choice